ciao marino s benvenuti alla seconda
puntata del traduttore di marina
in particolare oggi ci occuperemo di
tradurre quelle che sono le frasi che
dicono più spesso i figli
cosa hai fatto oggi a scuola niente
in realtà la prossima te ha interrogato
sorpresa e ovviamente ha interrogato me
ho preso 4 alla verifica di storia ho
copiato tutto perché ieri non ho
studiato niente e sono anche andato a
sbattere contro classe senti dimmi un po
chi chi chi c'è a questa festa chi c'è
tutti i miei compagni di classe mama non
conosco nessuno degli invitati
so solo che ci fa il ragazzo che mi
piace e quindi ci devo essere per forza
ma no niente altro
mi devi comprare dei vestiti a me ma va
no non mi piace nessuno mi piace metà
della mia scuola
e allora sai cosa ti dico che non ti
parlerò mai più habana tra mezz'ora però
chiederti che cosa c'è per cena
se mamma adesso sistemo sistemerò ma
solo dopo aver chiamato la mia amica
aver fatto dei tic toc aver solcato mac
su instagram essermi messa lo smalto
tranquilla ma mi sento molto bene oggi o
tre interrogazioni e non ho studiato
niente mamma te lo giuro che tutta la
classe ha preso brutti voti
in realtà sono l'unica che è andata male
ma se ti dico che tutti gli altri sono
andati male è penserà anche la verifica
era particolarmente difficile e quindi
sarai un pelino meno incazzata con me sì
mamma ok va bene dai mamma non rompere
fammi finire di fare quello che sto
facendo mamma ciao io esco mamma
tranquilla sto uscendo con le mie amiche
per favore non mi chiamarono i tre
secondi non mi stare addosso grazie opa
la smetti ha solo un mio amico bosto in
realtà è il mio fidanzato
ma se te lo dicessi non mi faresti più
mettere piede fuori casa quindi è solo
un amico ma va là studiare la gioia
ciao mamma vado a cazzeggiare da giulia
papa ma non armati pare che ho bevuto lo
sai che bevo solo coca cola quando vado
a ballare
la coca cola c'era ma c'era anche tanto
rum
adesso voglio studiare o l'abbiocco pos
pranzo e voglio rilassarmi un po sul
divano l'ultima cosa che voglio fare è
mettermi a studiare cara mamma che sta
studiando sto studiando cosa rispondere
a quello stronzo del mio ex che si è
rifatto sentire ma mai solo una
festicciola in casa siamo tutte femmine
poi è il party dell'anno alcol a fiumi e
gente che limone sui divanetti ciao a
dormire la giulia vado a dormire dal mio
ragazzo del quale tu non conosci
l'esistenza
e sì a casa libera arrivo quando avrò
finito di fare quello che sto facendo
arriverò o ma vuoi che ti dia una mano
in casa a lavare stirare ha bisogno io
sono qui e ti sto per chiedere di
comprarmi qualcosa si tornò presto non
tornerò presto si mamma adesso lo faccio
non lo farò mai
eccoci purtroppo arrivati alla fine del
video spero che anche questa seconda
parte del traduttore di marina vi sia
piaciuta fatemi sapere con un commento
qui sotto quale di queste frasi di te
più spesso ai vostri genitori e
soprattutto fatemi sapere se volete una
terza parte del traduttore di marina se
non l'avete ancora fatto mi raccomando
iscrivetevi al mio canale e cliccate
sulla campanella vicino al tasso
d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre
aggiornati su tutti i nuovi video e
seguitemi su tutti gli altri social
facebook
instagram e tic toc al prossimo video
d'oro ciao
[Musica]